we've got jason who's in traverse city
michigan jason how are you
i'm doing well good uh good to speak
with you chris john
yeah how can we help you today bud well
i am
a future everyday millionaire uh that is
trying to get past
how to get to that point with a
financial decision that i'm looking at
i've been debt-free since 2013 i
i have no debt i've got money packed
away
and i'm looking at purchasing a property
mini storage
units because i got a late start on my
retirement and i think this would be
a fast track to getting a retirement
income post work
that will supply me with a steady income
in my years of retirement basically
okay so what for what you're looking at
what's the dollar amount
all right so here's what i've got uh the
property currently has one mini storage
unit on it plus one large
pole barn with storage the property is
generating only about a thousand dollars
a month
so it needs to be expanded so i'm
looking at a
four hundred thousand dollar mortgage
essentially which will include
the purchase and erection of two new
multi-unit uh buildings which
in turn will allow me to have a much
larger shovel to dig out of this
debt the income that comes from this
property is not needed
i run my own business and i can easily
live off my
my current income as well as if
necessary
pay for this property on top of that
okay so you what how much are you making
a year right now
uh let's let's just round it into a
medium of
80k okay and how much money do you have
sitting ready to be used as an
investment
uh minus my emergency fund which is a
pretty healthy emergency fund
uh let's say 100k liquid okay
and so in looking at this in the
multi-unit how many units are you
talking total
uh two buildings two additional
buildings with approximately
32 to 36 units per building okay
32 to 36 and the average rental price
would be how much per unit
uh granted you'll have different five
five
sizes
eight eight by ten ten by twelve but on
average what's the
storage fee uh
i've done an overall calculation and i
know that each one of these buildings on
a conservative
occupancy with conservative rental rates
should generate between 25 and 3 000 a
month
and that's that's not max max capacity
obviously
okay what about these buildings is over
and above the thousand dollars a month
you're generating now
uh i'm sorry
are these new buildings you're going to
build bigger fancier
what what makes them different the
current the current mini unit that's on
there is only a 16 unit
uh building
is it old is it full at capacity oh yes
yes yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah
that one's full of capacity and there
are the
the large pole building has just open
space for
random space storage okay yeah
cars boats hey jason you said you had a
super healthy emergency fund
of course that jumped out at me how much
over and above a six-month emergency
fund do you have
uh let's let's call it another 40
000. okay so 100 so essentially push
come to serve you got 140 140k that you
could use toward this
if i needed to but tell me if my logic
tell me if my logic is correct here or
if i'm
going in the wrong direction part of the
reason i want to keep as much of my
liquid cash available is that way i can
use that for
better negotiations for concrete work or
building erection
uh rental equipment to do excavation
things of that nature i got you
along with just having just making sure
yeah here's the deal i can hear it in
your head you're a serial entrepreneur
um and you are itching to take on debt
and and and that's where philosophically
we're going to differ
like you know when i look at this and
say hey first thing shirts in any
business i'm going to tell you to work
on a business plan i want to know what
competition is in the area
how many other storage units are there
in in your area or the area you're
thinking about living
are they at capacity or is it an over
saturation
uh where there's too much also you also
have to be aware just like with a rental
property
yes you do have these things that you're
putting up and it's new and on the
starting you're going to do it but
what's the rate of people falling off
the wagon and not paying
then you're having to now go in and do
auctions and clear-outs of this thing
so i don't think it's as passive as
you're thinking it is
is this something that in a year you got
140 000 let's just say straight up that
you could use
in capital uh could you get a little bit
more intentional you're self-employed
making 80.
i think you're pulling my leg there a
little bit uh you might be making more
than this
but but looking at this is this
something i would strive to do with cash
absolutely i would or a very short-term
loan
where maybe you're you're you're
financing 50 50
of it uh and i'm saying if then uh to me
i just
you i i i feel like you're going to not
only do this but then you're going to go
on and do something else
and the next thing you know you're gonna
look up you're gonna have a million
dollars in debt and wonder how you got
there
so i would adopt a cash debt-free kind
of mentality
with any business that you're going into
uh to start small
and maybe you start small maybe you
start with what 140
000 get me can i get that to capacity
and get that humming
and then save up money to be able to add
the next one instead of
building the grand poobah mom's build a
little pub
that's right and anytime you're trying
to do something
to quote-unquote play catch-up yeah i
feel like i screwed up in the past i
haven't invested enough and so now i'm
staring down the barrel of retirement so
i found a shortcut you start doing
napkin math
that makes that shortcut work for you so
you can forgive yourself for the
challenges you did in the past yeah
don't make another mistake on top of
your mistake there you go when you try
to hit a grand slam it increases the
odds of striking out there you go so
just stay focused on hitting base hits
people
base hits with cash it'll get you there
this is the ramsey show